hey guys Ryan right here Alex Luthor the
guy who does all those epic fan-made
trailers I saw that he just came out
with Superman vs Hulk
epic battle trailer now you might be
going he's wearing a Superman shirt
right now is he rooting for Superman no
I'm not ready for any of them but I will
tell you which one I think will win in
the end
Superman it's Superman you just can't
beat Superman
you can't like his powers just come from
the [ __ ] atmosphere and stuff the
Hulk's
stuff was designed inside of humanity
Superman just has like an allergic
reaction that gives him superpowers
based off that knowledge that's why I
think Superman will way
[Music]
[Music]
which
[Music]
people there which month 24 minutes
seven seconds me about someone something
[Music]
we're sweeping every wirelessly
accessible camera on the country
cellphones laptops
[Music]
that's why I'm bringing it
[Music]
Thank You director Shi
[Music]
can you imagine happy doing this kind of
them react if they live there is someone
like this acting
[Music]
no I
[Music]
do you really think he has a chance
y'all got something
[Music]
after flight Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice good editing there
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was good at editing that was really
good okay
like I gotta admit like the first before
the battle started happening I
I thought the editing wasn't the
greatest that we've seen from these
fan-made trailers I was like okay yeah
but that's clearly a different time of
day when they were cutting back and
forth law at the time the transitions
weren't the smoothest a lot but it was
still good for the most part but when I
got the battle sequences that was cool I
found myself getting really engrossed as
if this was a real thing you know
sometimes I watch he's not they're
always awesome
and I'm thinking like wow look how
impressive this is but I was getting
really engrossed feeling like I was
watching a legit trailer between
Superman versus the Hulk and then I got
kind of bummed out when I realized that
this is fake but you know that's the
sign of a great fan made trailer I would
love to see a Wolverine versus the Hulk
version if you could make that happen
that'd be very impressive Alex Luthor
Luthor I forgot your name is Alex yeah
[ __ ] great [ __ ] great editing still I
mean like he knows how to take footage
and turn it into a different story that
I love so much that the concept of the
whole kind of being out of control so
the recruiting Superman that makes the
most sense out of all the stories Unitel
Nance the linemen all love were look
perfect and I thought it was really
interesting how he took footage from
Godzilla I'm Ken Watanabe threw that in
there as the scientist talking about
Bruce Banner and stuff that was that was
neat smart move there a little
distracting at times but smart move
anyway guys thanks for informing me that
this video is out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and you can follow me on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook that's
right I have been plugged into the
social networks people
it's happening it's happening I didn't
realize all the [ __ ] I could get away
with doing on them Eric Cooper sup real
rejects how are you that's nice
I'm doing fine myself huh I'm gonna ask
you don't care
I suppose you're trying to find a point
to all of this you bet your ass I am I'm
not sure there is one [ __ ] you I mean I
could tell you about how I discover your
channel or what I do okay
I'm suppose you were looking at a
trailer or something and I guess I'll do
exactly that
I found your channel not that long ago
maybe a week or so ago this is from
February 22nd so well
watch your reaction to the DBZ battle of
gods trailer and thought it was pretty
funny Thanks then I move on to watch a
bunch of your game trailer reactions and
decided I'd subscribe wonderful story
but enough about that let's move on to
me I make videos sometimes my friends
would like me to make them more often
but I hardly get around to it I'm the
key not war on YouTube if you feel like
looking me up I'm also making a game
although I haven't worked on it for a
long time I guess you could say the
point of this message just to get a
shout out or something I guess that's
for you to decide I have a tendency to
write on points in case you couldn't
tell okay at least you acknowledge that
part here's what it takes to build a
channel not me getting in your face
telling you to grow a pair of balls man
up quit being a [ __ ] go out there and
make something of yourself
no that doesn't work what it takes is
self motivation self motivation when I
was first starting out this channel I
was like I gotta get popular so that way
I could get Veronica I was like dang if
I could just get a little famous like a
couple thousand subscribers she'd be
like I want that and bam what do you
know 50,000 subscribers later anyway
Aaron Cooper and I'm not gonna lie don't
know how old you are you look like an
adult you are one scary-looking
[ __ ]
I'm not gonna say this joke because it'd
be [ __ ] up but it does involve a head
and skin
so that's I hope you don't have like a
disease horrible in me Brian just never
stopped